[Musique]
un couteau bien aiguisé fait toute la
différence combien de temps de cuisiner
notre expert Frédéric Chabot a évalué 10
appareils pour affûter nos couteaux à la
maison
accessible c'est ce qui est simple à
utiliser
les affuteurs manuels sont les plus
courants ils sont constitués d'une à
trois fentes avec des grains abrasifs
évolutifs de grossier à très fin la
fourchette de prix de notre sélection se
situe entre 21 et 120 dollars
Frédéric je commence en vous demandant
lequel j'achète
et Seigneur d'excellente question
et ça a l'air douloureux en fait comme
pour bien des choses dans lui c'est
difficile de tout avoir dans le même
appareil
et les affuteurs
à
utiliser qui mesure
le tournage
il y a un couteau qui est associé à
chaque appareil
d'abord notre expert a enlevé le
tranchant des couteaux en utilisant une
brique pour ensuite procéder au test
le principe de base pour affûter un
couteau et le même pour tous les
appareils de notre bande dessin
c'est-à-dire replacer le fil soit le
tranchant du couteau c'est cette partie
qu'on a faite on passe alors le couteau
entre deux abrasifs en forme de V
il y a deux choses qui ont doit faire
quand on a fait une lame il faut retirer
du métal surtout de ces cylindres mais
vraiment émoussé faut vraiment y aller
finement doucement pour polir le ciel le
tranchant de la lame chaque appareil
subit au moins 4 5 affûtages complets la
moitié des appareils qui arrivait c'est
que des fois la qualité de l'affûtage se
détériorer au lieu de s'améliorer pour
ramener ce tranchant trois types
d'abrasifs sont utilisés la céramique le
carbure de tungston et le diamant
certains appareils vont avoir un seul
type ou deux types ou une combinaison
des trois types est-ce que un de ces
trois abrasifs là qui est à privilégier
le carbure de tungstène se mettant les
obus par exemple donc c'est vraiment
très très dur et
ça va agir un peu comme un rabot deux
affûtteurs n'ont que ce type de braisé
à ramener un tranchant
instantanément c'est lui qui enlève le
plus de métal mais la finition est
tellement brute que mon tranchant reste
pas longtemps sur mon couteau tout ce
qui est un céramique une action beaucoup
plus douce il va être moins efficace va
être moins rapide donc si votre plan est
très émoussé ça va en prendre beaucoup
de passage pour le ramener tranchant
mais souvent la qualité du tranchant de
la qualité du film va être meilleur
le VIH de zwelling et le minouchable de
Global sont les deux seuls à naître
pourvu que de céramiques
et les deux seuls dans l'abrasif peut
être remplacé une fois usée
qui ont des textures plus ou moins
abrasives qui reprennent le principe de
la pierre à aiguiser et on peut mettre
de l'eau alors il faut savoir que chez
les professionnels ils vont utiliser des
grosses meules qui idéalement vont être
refroidis à l'eau parce que la vitesse
et la pression de la lame sont la meule
va faire surchauffer madame et à partir
du moment que la lame chauffe on dégrade
la qualité du métal ici le tuyau aucun
danger que je surchauffe la lame il y a
le diamant aussi c'est du diamant
industriel qui est collé sur un support
en métal et qui va agir comme le du
papier sablé aussi ça peut être des
grains fins comme des grains plus
grossiers le Ricardo par exemple ces
deux fentes sont en diamant donc une
fente avec un diamant plus grossier pour
les premiers passages et on va finir
après ça sur un diamant qui est beaucoup
plus fin
[Musique]
le Masterchef et le sanchy sont les
seuls appareils de notre bande dessin
qui offrent les trois sortes d'abrasifs
lui je s'impressionnant où il est
efficace j'avais beaucoup d'espoir dans
lui parce qu'on peut ajuster l'angle
alors faut-il savoir que j'ai sur le
film de mon couteau comment je sais moi
que mon couteau il y a un angle pour
aller dans cet appareil ou pas c'est
très rare que ça va être une information
qui va être fournie et ce qu'il va
falloir faire c'est utiliser la flûteur
plusieurs fois tranquillement la lame va
venir prendre l'angle de l'acheteur les
appareils qui m'aident un petit peu plus
à garder ma lame droite
vont me donner des meilleurs résultats
les abrasifs du village de Vueling sont
montés sur des ressorts peu importe la
pression que je vais donner les abrasifs
vont vous adapter donc c'est toujours
bien important de toujours garder la
lame parfaitement horizontale et
verticale il y a quand même des chances
que je bouge un peu malade mais
possiblement moins qu'avec les autres
c'est l'appareil là selon son vœu avoir
des résultats plus rapides ou plus en
finesse on va juste changer l'angle ce
qui fait que il y a beaucoup de chance
que le couteau soit pas toujours très
bien placé
un bout de ligne les résultats varient
énormément alors j'achète lequel
c'est une excellente question ça dépend
de vos habitudes ça dépend de vos
couteaux le Welling le vie Edge pas
vraiment des céramiques très douces
c'est vraiment lui qui donne le plus
beau film et c'est lui qui est le plus
long aussi je vais pouvoir passer le
couteau plusieurs fois le Welling étant
à 120 dollars plusieurs vont préférer le
Ricardo beaucoup plus abordable le
Ricardo ce qui va être assez rapide qui
va être assez efficace donc j'ai pas
besoin de penser la lame 200 fois dedans
pour acheter mon couteau et fait une
qualité de fil aussi qui est quand même
assez bonne la grande conclusion de tout
ça c'est de s'acheter un couteau neuf et
d'en prendre soin à tous les jours avec
un appareil qui va affûter doucement
sans abîmer la lame